[Music]
in harsh punishment news Oh harsh
submitted by hot cheetos are better than
what yeah cuz they are very good they
are I have to admit there Bob one of the
best a woman was jailed for a criminal
damage to a can of Pringles what does
she do cuz it didn't belong to her she
stole it from someone and she's just
like step on it and they were like I'm
pressing charges because I pay for this
[ __ ] this my [ __ ] property
criminal damage I think Pringles are
cool but they're one of the most
unsatisfying potato chips they are
they're my least favorite potato chip
sour cream and onion chili is one of the
best I have nothing against the flavors
I don't like the texture because salt
and vinegar sour cream and onion button
lays right it's crispier
I like Pringles cuz they're like yeah
they're not greasy they're like thin
right tidal chips right there well chips
it's the hard one it's crunchy yeah
that's good the same flavor across her
so distinct yeah but the Pringles is
literally the dehydrated mashed potato
powder yeah that's a funky and it's half
it's like you have to chip half cracker
you guys gotta eat it you gotta eat it
at three times at once you get three
chips and then it's satisfying one is
not enough
I love Pringles man it's because they're
against it I eat them I eat him you
[ __ ] after right with Pringles dude
[ __ ] what cuz he eats the Pringles and
then he makes the [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] make I know how to make a pocket
[ __ ] out of the Pringles k there's an
emotional connection he [ __ ] the
Pringles after he eats it so you take
two sponges all the boys right now are
like this that's a different type of
circle yeah you just take a latex glove
and then you take other sponges and then
a rubber band and then you go inside out
put the rubber band on it and then
that's it jail style yeah yeah Vaseline
that's pretty good so you know you could
do that with the Pringles you can't you
can't do that with the waste two sponges
now you gotta tell you little sponges
you get a dollar sponge
what kind of sponge do you get well you
could go to Walmart or what do you
prefer I have like real toys I don't I
only do that if I go back home
bring that on the airplane just bring
the Pringles and the two sponges that's
like a fear of mine why like being katli
in your backpack with a flashlight so
masturbation for you is like a whole
experience oh yeah preparation
preparation and more preparation you're
involving everything yeah yeah I used my
heater to warm up whatever I'm warming
up yeah to meet you human light do you
fill up a sink with hot water and then
leave your flashlight in there to warm
up No
how do you warm it as a heater like a
professional flashlight heater oh yeah
but that's so much work just to jack off
though I know I love it though it feels
great you know what am i growing around
that's what I got
yeah the heater and the heater yeah and
then I have an awesome shoutout to
officer Cara she gave me a double-sided
flashlight where I can use both sides is
that her [ __ ] I have hers too as well
is it weird to like to use your friend
yeah yeah yeah we could get into that
yeah it did it feel a little weird once
I met her you kept doing it well yeah
well that's when I switched to the other
toy the other [ __ ]
well after you met her yeah cuz it's
weird cuz it's like they molded it after
her that's like my sister you know you
can never just masturbate without that
with my hand yeah like an animal no way
that's like prehistoric times Wow no I'm
dealing with yeah
I'm not some next-level [ __ ] what you
say I had a flashlight you do I felt
guilty after I came in it why why did
you go guilty well there's two I by
myself
and then I showed my girlfriend at the
time that I had one and she was curious
so she [ __ ] used it on me and [ __ ]
beat me off with it she did it
yeah and then afterwards I'm like damn
oh that's next level but then after I
busted it I was like I was like you know
what it felt like it felt like I had a
dead hooker in my room and I kept
[ __ ] it so I had to throw it away
[ __ ] that's how I felt like weird well I
don't mess with it I did before but now
her I know I got a girl too but you know
something what if she goes in the gym
while we lived together he uses it I
thought she was going away four days
apart but let me ask you something what
happens when she has to go to the
bathroom that's a lot she goes out there
it's the watch TV like what are you
doing here what do you say that I met
when she goes when she goes away to
Germania yeah Eastern European country
huh yeah so that's good that's growth
for you isn't it cuz you don't you know
cuz uh you think it's deviant behavior
cuz I want to no no you could do
whatever you want to just be real with
me you're a sick [ __ ] freak no I
think you can do whatever you want or
whatever is healthy for your
relationship she knows about it some
people got some people got swing sets
what do you wanna be a swing set looking
like like swing set like [ __ ] swings
like we're [ __ ] weird I know but
what's a [ __ ] swing so they got like
swings that are made for sex we people
have like built out rooms made to
pleasure each other yeah that's a
different level that we're getting out
of your house we can just have a room
you don't haven't told you guys the
story yet I know this is the story
alright so this story here it's about
this woman who apparently has 14
convictions Wow for theft and to
criminal damage she was banned from this
one particular store like she was not
supposed to be there and so she wanted
to buy some Pringles but then a security
guy came up to her and said hey you're
not supposed to be here leave the
preamble isn't like just leave and then
she ended up opening the Pringles she
was like I opened it now you have to let
me pay for it and then that's when they
called the cops and then she was
arrested Oh for causing damage to this
Pringle because now they can't resell it
and they refused to sell it to her
because she was so they take it as back
yes damn I always do that when I'm in
the store no okay yeah and she was she
was
and from that store oh yeah this 25 year
old girl named Kathleen it's like we
don't even why your business here so she
was ended up being jailed and the her
lawyer was like trying to ask for
leniency because she's a newlywed and
she's five months pregnant
oh no yeah she's gonna create other
idiots I know but then the court said
that she this was smart aleck behavior
it is so the judge ended up something
sentencing her for five months even with
the baby but not for four months
suspending in the last two months of the
sentence they're jailed her for four
months of spending the last two months
of the sentence okay cuz they're
supposed to be six but they're giving
her just for ya stupid breed stupid yeah
oh mighty book makes me so sad but it's
like so extreme to just first I'm single
no it's not cuz she had 14 convictions
and she's bad there's a record of
stupidity [ __ ] yeah like if that wasn't
her first thing then I'd be like that's
wild like they went a little to him on
her that's what she does that's her [ __ ]
that's your [ __ ] yeah yeah people like
stealing stuff huh yeah it's kind of fun
she's trying to pay for it but then dude
I don't steal anymore when you're
younger you did hell yeah me too it was
not fun
what'd you used to steal a lot of things
I'll give you an example I'll tell you
my story like Walkman buttknocker
buttknocker
it was not an civ dude anymore but um
back in the day was this summit demo yes
yes yeah it was really good I don't know
they probably like killed your taste
buds or some chickens actually was harsh
dude it likes the undertone yeah it was
good but it was good dog
it's like God I seen that time ago long
chats like a thick pen like a long
chapstick yeah like this this big a
small ISA or something it was a spray
yup feud still that yeah what else did
you steal at like if we've gone to a
department store like cologne yep
oh that's ring I know Sam Goody's in the
warehouse
oh yeah like music cassette tapes CDs we
all stole but we don't steal anymore why
is it so I think we learn that
no because you guys have sons like what
would you do if you caught your son they
got caught stealing dude old ass a Latin
style cut off their head a Latin dude
king of beasts today I accidentally
steal
I would not how do you accidentally
because I'll be looking at things at the
market and I'd be like oh I'm gonna get
this for later and I put it in my pocket
put it in your pocket jump because you
know how my brain is conscious of it and
you do it is that stealing knows you're
not aware of it instead of having a cart
or something it's like a place to just
hold it with the intention to buy I'm
gonna buy it yeah and then later when I
get home I have a melty chocolate in my
pocket you're asking for trouble you're
just dancing with the devil yeah that's
right your pocket I know but now dancing
with the devil you say don't just don't
buy any more passive pockets okay me and
my girl we're at the Grove at a candy
store yeah you know your sample right
you sample when we left she had a grip
more like on those strawberry strips and
gummy bears that's the early that's is
it yes she should be jailed what's her
name
I think you should only sample fruit but
there are gummy bears there like you
know yet if it's allowed it's innocent
stealing wouldn't you say someone paid
good money for that because you're
sampling no you're not that's dealing
cuz this you have your that's okay if
your son's got like if they were like
God if they took like five gummy bears
or whatever or strips he's walking it
back even if they don't sell it you have
to teach your molester I might go back
if I caught him then in there
and sampling is one bear if you have
five bears and all the same flavor bit
four dollars worth in also collect in
that's not sampling that's sample
no I want to know what other flavors
taste like the definition of stealing
doesn't change because of intent yes I
know see that if you want to get
technical stealing is when you leave the
premises right no no what do you mean
stealing is when you take something
that's not yours yeah without paying for
it
yeah and was it a sample like you just
create your own definition for skipping
yeah for the candies is the minute you
have the gummy bears if it's in your
pocket or in your mouth that's stealing
and if they don't have sample sections
like if their policy is is not the
sample then you're stealing I didn't see
any sign what if you went to a brothel
and then you asked for a [ __ ] sample
and she goes cool so she licks it once
you go I want 20 more samples until you
nut and you don't pay for it and you
walked out that's feeling right the
great one and then when you're picking
it were you like looking around or were
you like all these are good I think I
might buy these like were you doing that
no I was like looking if they may have
looked my way I need someone on my side
David can you back me up I can't back
you up can you back me up here
I really would back you up but I
literally called my woman a thief for
sampling so I have to stick to my guns
ok at the grocery store they have this
licorice I like is it in a package it's
in a barrel yeah but it doesn't say
sample no listen to me I take one or two
and it's doing that steal no cuz I want
to know what it tastes like
alright you're at the bread aisle right
and you know how all bread kind of
tastes slightly different but it's
packaged do you open the package of each
one and go I wonder what this would
taste like you know you know what
doesn't he doesn't he what do you do
that with bread what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so you're the reason why I
got that loaf of bread with a [ __ ]
bite mark on it I would never do that to
a bread friend no no might as well do
yours haha
all right you know I apologize I gotta
make it
yeah so the candy store at the Grove I
took one too many strips and gummy bears
I owe you $3 he's the kind of guy that
throws $3 worth the candy I'd like to 13
[Music]